it has been and still is a hard time for
many but tonight we turn the page in two
weeks I will send this Congress a budget
filled with ideas that are practical not
partisan we can't put the security of
families at risk by taking away their
health insurance or unraveling the new
rules on Wall Street or refighting past
battles on immigration when we've got to
fix a broken system and if a bill comes
to my desk that tries to do any of these
things I will veto it plan we make
quality childcare more available and
more affordable for every middle-class
and low-income family with young
children in America
send me a bill that gives every worker
in America the opportunity to earn seven
days of paid sick leave sending this
Congress a bold new plan to lower the
cost of Community College to zero I'm
launching a new precision medicine
initiative to bring us closer to curing
diseases like cancer and diabetes and to
give all of us access to the
personalized information we need to keep
ourselves and our families healthier I
intend to protect a free and open
Internet extend its reach to every
classroom in every community let's close
loopholes so we stop rewarding companies
that keep profits abroad and reward
those that invest here in America and
let's close the loopholes that lead to
inequality by allowing the top 1% to
avoid paying taxes on their accumulated
wealth we lead best when we combine
military power with strong diplomacy
when we leverage our power with
coalition building that's exactly what
we're doing right now and around the
globe it is making a difference and
tonight I call on this Congress to show
the world that we are united in this
mission by passing a resolution to
authorize the use of force against ISIL
and tonight I urge this Congress to
finally pass the legislation we need to
better meet the evolving threat of cyber
attacks a brighter future is ours to
write let's begin this new chapter
together